there's nowhere worse than Dubai because
the promiscuity in Dubai amongst men and
women is the only city in the world
where the women are far more promiscuous
than a man far more because what's
happened to the women that come to rich
cities is they come emotionally detached
they come with the idea that I want to
meet a rich man now that woman is
completely different to the woman that
comes to a city and says I want to fall
in love and have kids now that
emotionally detached woman who comes I
want a good life is never emotionally
invested and here's the mistake a lot of
rich men make they seem to think that if
they can support a girl and give her a
good life loyalty is a given but what
they're forgetting is a woman that
craves a good life doesn't seek
emotional intimacy she seeks financial
intimacy any woman who doesn't seek
emotional intimacy is far more likely to
stray
what's your background for the people
that don't know you
my name is Sadia I am a relationship
coach I used to be a psychology teacher
I studied psychology and then I went on
to do my masters in Psychotherapy and
education so I was teaching psychology
for many many years in London and Dubai
and then only about a year ago about a
year or so ago I decided to kind of give
a little bit of the relationship advice
that I learned in in my studies I
thought let me just post one or two
videos and because it seems like there's
a gap of understanding in the market I
just saw so many podcasts teaching the
wrong things I thought let me just give
a little bit of advice and
um it kind of went a little bit big on
social media so now I I stopped teaching
and I've gone into full-time
um relationship coaching
what is it that you see on the internet
with regards to relationship advice that
was the most egregious what were people
getting most wrong that lit a fire under
your psychology background
um I think what I couldn't understand is
why we were pitting men and women
against each other I couldn't understand
that battle I didn't understand what
positive outcomes could ever come from
making men think women are users and
abusers and they're awful and women
thinking men are dangerous and
aggressive and cheats I couldn't
understand
um where this anger and hostility was
coming from and more so I didn't
understand how it's going to benefit
people by thinking like this so I just
wanted to debunk some of this kind of uh
the Zeitgeist to just kind of hate the
opposite gender why do you think that
has become so prevalent
I think what's happened is firstly it's
great for clickbait it's fantastic for
like because lonely people are attached
to what they see on the internet the
most so when you're saying something
that triggers the people that have been
hurt they are going to share repost
watch Etc so when we tap into vulnerable
people or people who've been broken on
her we're going to get more views we're
going to blow up quicker and easier so I
think tapping into you know online
success they want to divide and conquer
that's always a best strategy the other
thing is is that a lot of people
actually haven't had relationship
experiences especially the younger
generation they haven't had that much
experience so they learn a lot of it
from watching online and watching memes
and so on and so forth so I think it's
become people's template they use the
internet as a template for relationships
if they have been modeled at home and as
a result that's why they stick to the
the information that they're getting
online
I tweeted literally just before we got
started the cynicism safety blanket
cynicism is a guarded response you're
setting yourself up against
disappointment its role within the
system is to protect you against
experiencing anything bad it is a
preemptive strike against a perceived
threat if I tell myself that all women
are bad then I'm less likely to seek
relationship with women and as a
consequence I'm never going to feel the
pain of rejection if I tell myself that
everything is [__] or that things will
never get better then I'm excused of
ever having to try anything it's more
comfortable to get fatalistic and call
it pragmatism the cope is framing hope
as pathetic and embarrassing and
optimism as delusion it's sour grapes at
an existential level if everything sucks
and everyone is horrible and reality is
disappointing and you know that for a
fact it's the people acting like things
can be better that are dumb delusional
and the problem the upside of never
having to feel the pain of failure
very impressive post Chris what can I
say uh my point being that I think if
someone we have a generalized risk
aversion at the moment young people are
getting their driving license later
they're having less casual sex they're
drinking alcohol less they're taking
fewer drugs they are starting getting
jobs later in life every it's slow life
strategy everything is getting pushed
out because people don't deal with risk
particularly well and you know even if
you're a sigma male gym emo it's still
the same on your side too that you're
prepared to do hard things but only
within the bounds of what you consider
to be acceptably hard and yeah this
adversarial relationship or nature
that's being sort of posited is men and
women are each other's enemies something
that I've noticed
um and the same thing goes for I guess
people just being concerned about okay
what what does the future hold I will
take all of my cues about this from the
internet
yeah exactly that what happens is
especially when we have low self-esteem
um when we've got low self-esteem the
ego has to find ways to defend itself we
need to defend our ego because we don't
have pure self-love and self-esteem and
the quickest and easiest way to defend
your ego is by rejecting what may reject
you if I quickly say oh who wants ABS I
don't have to go to the gym if I quickly
say oh God men are trash I don't have to
work on myself to sustain a positive
relationship if I quickly reject what I
believe will reject me I then defend
myself against the possibility of any
kind of new trauma so it's usually a
trauma response but really it's stemming
from low self-esteem and I I that's what
it screams to me when I see these people
who are trying to divide men and women
and almost take pleasure out of
insulting the opposite gender I I just
never understood it
shared hatreds are much more cohesive
than shed lobes and getting people to
bind together over the mutual distaste
of an out group is significantly easier
than the mutual love of an in-group
which is why there are incentives online
for creators to do this
um exactly that because here's the thing
not every Creator is trying to change
your life for the better most creators
are trying to sell you something they're
trying to get popularity they're
designed to polarize they're designed to
kind of make it online and uh you know
and anybody could say the same for me
they're saying like oh you're trying to
you know blow up and all this stuff
which I I I hope people know that's not
really the intention but the reality is
most creators are creating they're not
actually healing and the problem is they
appeal to the young Market because
there's a gap the older psychologists
who understand all the academic
references and all of those things they
don't understand the young Market of
dating and because of that huge gap the
young people are thinking I don't need
to go to an expert I'll just go to this
podcast with that guy and this girl and
they'll tell me because they get it they
don't get it they just get you they get
what you're going through and want to
manipulate your vulnerabilities in order
for you to become a consumer of this
I've heard you say that current dating
is just practicing for divorce what's
that mean
it means you're learning the tools and
skills required to recover from a
breakup rather than how to maintain a
marriage so you are learning how to make
somebody jealous how to move on quickly
how to meet somebody new how to play
hard to get how to play games how to
essentially ensure your relationship
will not make it through the tough times
you're not learning how to sustain and
maintain and how to debunk some of the
behaviors in yourself that are toxic to
the relationship you're just learning
how to categorize every X of yours as a
narcissist but not about what behaviors
or traits in you attract or even are
narcissistic so I think the current
dating climate is purely how do I move
on how do I protect myself how do I not
get to attach catch flights not feelings
that culture is what we're being taught
I guess this is similar to what we said
before the risk aversion the guarded
response mm-hmm
exactly that that's what it is well I
mean in your opinion have you noticed
that as well like from a man's
perspective I mean I've noticed it as a
woman because I remember trying to share
something positive about men
um and I couldn't find a meme online I
was looking and scrolling I was trying
to find something to show how lovely it
is when you're loved by a man and I
scrolled for hours and hours and I
couldn't find anything but when I try
and look for a meme that will say men
are this men are that within a second
and then that was my wake-up moment
because I was just like even if I wanted
to say something positive about my
partner I can't find anything online
um and then I realized that it is a
culture of getting you to hate men is it
the same in for men do you find that the
same kind of cultures being trying to be
breeded
certainly in terms of
men having distaste for women uh you
know like don't worry King you don't
need her she's just a hoe in any case
like Sigma signal means abound yeah
there's a lot less positivity from Men
to Men generally right I think that
there are still pro-women women women
cohorts yeah but there are fewer pro-men
male cohuts and um you know that's
partly just because of the trend yeah
everyone says like women will give their
uh give people compliments and not mean
them men will take the piss out of each
other and not mean it it's yeah that
kind of balance but it it can mean you
know think about Jordan Peterson right
why he came onto the scene so much and
he he used to tear up all the time
telling the same story which was these
men have never had a positive word told
to them their entire lives they've never
been encouraged they've never been told
that they are worthy of Love or
acceptance or praise or validity or any
of that yeah why did that message
resonate because so many men felt and
still do feel like no one sees them that
life can be hard that they do have
emotions that they do want to open up
that they do need support that they do
want to be praised in a way and because
there is nothing deeper I think because
there is still a challenge in maybe men
opening up themselves is some of the
boundaries of that have been broken but
the boundaries of men responding to men
that have opened up definitely still
exist in a massive massive way so okay
what are the ways in which I can get
some validation from the world well
success money cars education women
status Prestige dominance aggression you
know all of these
they're like proxies for what a lot of
men want and that's not to say I want
all of those things as well right but
they're proxies for what men Miss I
think more spiritually and eggs
essentially
yeah I absolutely agree I feel like in
in my work when I've worked with men who
have turned to
um
prostitution and who have turned to
pornography addiction
um a lot of the time especially when
they turn to prostitution or even just a
gold digger
um they're so hurt when she doesn't like
them back
so they're not paying for sex they're
actually paying for intimacy and I
always tell them you can't buy intimacy
you can't buy it this girl you can buy
her a bag and you can have sex with her
but you're craving connection and that
is something you can't buy and the
reason they're craving connection is
because a they don't know where to find
it and also they're being told if they
do look for connection they're a simp
that word simp gets thrown around so
we've almost shamed men for wanting and
craving connection and I can say in
honestly the men that cheat the men that
tend to pornography the men that tend to
escorts I'm very non-judgmental because
I understand behind every
self-sabotaging Behavior there is a need
that has not been met for a really long
time and for that need to be met they
turn to self-destructive Behavior as a
coping mechanism so um I definitely
think that we've got a crisis of men
seeking intimacy but believing that it's
wrong and the culture and the internet
is also teaching them that it's wrong so
they're secretly craving it and then
secretly finding uh Outsourcing it in
the wrong ways
simping for women is wanting emotional
connection but somehow buying her a bag
and flying her all over the world is not
simping and that's the alpha male way to
do stuff
right yeah
you've said current dating is just
practicing for divorce there's a lot of
talk about the fragility of long-term
relationships and divorce rates going up
you've actually done some research
looking at what predicts divorce what
did you find
well I I have to give credit where
credit's due but the the most
long-standing Research into uh marriage
and relationships was by the gottman
institution and they did the most
scientific and objective analysis of
relationships and they studied 10 000
couples in a lab over a couple of days
and they were able to predict with 80
accuracy which couples would stay
together and which ones would get
divorced within a year and it was so
simple what they were able to find and
it was simple thing as responding to
each other's bids for connection what I
mean by this is when we have a
partnership where one person comes home
and expresses an emotion the other one
picks up on it that partnership has the
base levels to last a really long time
so it could be a simple thing like you
come home from work and say I'm so tired
and your partner says why what's wrong
simple connection from that connection
they've trust each other and then they
start to lean into each other but if you
come home and you're like I'm so tired
and your partner either says nothing or
says why are you tired I'm the one
that's been with the kids all day or
what have you done all day I've been at
work all day that turning away from each
other's emotional needs is the training
ground for divorce they are now setting
themselves up for divorce and it might
not happen today might not happen
tomorrow it might last another 10 15
years but we get emotionally exhausted
by having partners who reject our kind
of advances for connection and
eventually the relationship ends
why is it the case then that divorce
rates are rising
if that's the biggest predictor if
that's 80 accuracy of being able to
predict
why has that specific trait changed so
much over the last 50 years
distractions
distractions distractions distractions
there are alternatives to everything
even if you want a meal you'll have 50
alternatives on ubereats you want to go
out to eat there's 50 places that you
could go you want to watch something
there's 50 Alternatives of what to watch
there are so many alternatives to every
single asset aspect of life that it
makes it almost impossible to invest in
one everybody and everything becomes
disposable so what's happening is when
your partner comes home a bit tired or
stressed maybe in the past you'd pick up
on it but now you're on your phone or
maybe when your partner wanted to watch
a series that you didn't care about in
the past you may have been like okay
it's fine it's I'll just get on with it
there's nothing else on now like you
watch this I'm going to watch that
there's so many alternatives to
everybody and every every person is now
becoming so disposable that we can no
longer have the patience to invest in
people's emotional needs and we're
becoming so hedonistic that our
emotional needs come first and we're
being taught this in society
always talked about put you first
self-esteem self-assurance
self-actualization the word self is kind
of programmed in our psyche and the
collectivism that we used to have as a
society is gone so we're no longer
getting happiness from somebody else's
happiness it's a it's a selfish Pursuit
now unfortunately
isn't it strange that the trait of
focusing not on somebody else's desire
for connection is causing you to turn
inward that is causing divorces to
increase down the line which means that
people respond to that by being more
defensive by being more guarded and more
cynical which makes them turn further
inward which makes them less of an
eligible partner to the next
relationship which then just creates a
cycle that then gets broadcast onto the
internet people who haven't had much
experience in relationships because
they're young or because they fail out
or because they're concerned or nervous
or averted to risk
use that as their proxy and say right
well I'd better enter into this
relationship guarding myself so that I
don't get hurt which makes it more
likely that it's going to break up and
the cycle just continues
it's exactly that what happens is we're
actually entering relationships with our
armor up but in the process of playing
those games like not texting back uh not
getting too close not attaching not
telling them that you miss them not
telling them that you love them you are
training somebody to love you in the
wrong way if I'm somebody who's needy
and I actually need lots of love and
reassurance but I don't want to text
first and I don't want to be looking
needing I don't want to say I miss you
because I'm going to wait for him I'm
then teaching him that I'm cool calm and
collect and I don't care when I hear
from him if I see you I see you but then
he's under he's not getting the training
ground of what I truly want he's not
getting access to my true needs so I am
now no longer communicating effectively
I am actually teaching him how to love
in and in a very avoidant and dismissive
manner because I'm pretending to be cool
when really if I say look I need to
speak to my partner on a daily basis I
like to see you regularly I love you I
miss you what is this I like labels when
I start communicating my needs he will
actually learn how to love me but we're
teaching people to do the opposite we're
teaching people to pretend that they're
somebody else and especially pretend
that they're avoided pretend that
they're independent depend that they
pretend that they don't have these needs
so essentially we're going to attract
the wrong partner
what else have you found that is a
predictor of a toxic or a negative or a
declining relationship
a criticism over praise
um again with the research one of the
things that they find is partners that
last are ones that praise a substantial
amount compared to criticism so they
scan the environment to kind of Praise
their partner they'll look for excuses
to praise their partner like even if
it's as simple as like you make the bed
so good every time I come home the house
is clean these tiny things any
opportunity to praise their partner but
what happens in relationships that end
is they can't remember the last time
they complimented each other they think
it should be a given they think oh you
know I think you're pretty because I'm
with you aren't I or you know I'm
grateful that you pay the bills like I I
I'm you're a guy why do you need
compliments men are craving this I've
noticed a lot in in my practice and men
that often have affairs they're not
actually seeking sex they're seeking a
woman that complements them they say
they can't remember the last time a
woman told them that he looks great
words for women we our partner says
about also our friends will tell us
people will tell us yeah we've always
been told we're beautiful or whatever it
is but for men if their partner doesn't
tell them nobody does so when they meet
somebody who simply tells them they look
good they fit their intelligent
something to validate them they
immediately become attracted to that
because they're starved of it so praise
is something that I think couples forget
how important it is I suppose that the
game playing and the Rivalry that
sometimes happens in relationships as
they start to go downhill
that makes this situation worse because
you're not going to praise somebody that
you think is your rival or that you're
trying to play games with or that you're
unsure about the level of trust that you
should put in them whoever you don't
feel safe with thing is all of these
things I'm saying they only come when
you feel safe now simple things like
liking other girls pictures or following
people now makes people feel super
unsafe super super unsafe so then guards
go up I know people that the moment they
add somebody on Instagram and they see
who they're following they might have
had a really great date with them
everything was great but then they look
on their following like oh straight away
insecurities guards everything so we're
now unfortunately in an environment
where you're thrown into the deep end
all your insecurities can now come alive
through the use of social media so
people are going into relationships
ready for it to fall apart
you've done a ton of work on trauma
you've mentioned that word maybe a
couple of times already I live in Austin
Texas Austin Texas is the sort of place
where when I walk into a sauna someone
is talking about their trauma work that
they've just done at an MDMA and
ketamine therapy assisted sound bath in
South America and it's got me a little
turned off from the word I understand
the trauma is a big deal yeah I've had
guys on that run
psychedelic assisted therapy for PTSD
for veterans but
what is bollocks and what is not
bollocks in the world of trauma where
are people getting out over their skis
where is it truthful
well here's the thing there's trauma in
this stress stress is situational yeah
it happens you have a response to the
stress to what's going on and you're
stressed about it how you know something
is trauma is their response is
disproportionate to the scenario that
suggests that there is a pre-existing
wound some things happened before you
came along that made them hypersensitive
about the situation and their response
is disproportionate so whenever
somebody's response is disproportionate
to the scenario there's potentially a
wound now I am personally of the opinion
that for me personally all the holistic
kind of things don't necessarily work on
me I wouldn't really go do Ayahuasca and
I wouldn't really be able to just do a
bunch of affirmations for me personally
that doesn't work I from from my
experience and personally and I I would
love to hear what you what you think as
well for me the only way to outdo trauma
is to make better decisions in life your
trauma is kind of going to be always
leading you to self-destructive Parts
it's always going to lead you towards
self-sabotage your trauma is going to
teach you to live for today and not
worry about tomorrow it's going to tell
you to spend the money in the casino
it's going to tell you to pay for that
escort it's going to tell you to just
just indulge but when you stop and you
think start valuing yourself and making
good effective decisions you're going to
beat that trauma that trauma is like a
devil inside of you telling you to
almost kill yourself through vices but
when you stop and you take control and
you say I am going to make good
decisions I'm going to take self-control
you defeat the trauma all the other
types of Therapies in for me personally
I I really don't like to knock anything
because everybody's different it doesn't
work for me sitting in the mirror
telling myself I'm amazing it doesn't
work I can sit there and say you're
gorgeous you're beautiful I'm never
going to believe that but if I say get
to the gym don't eat carbs for today
don't eat sugars after this time I don't
care what my children was telling me
I'll start to feel more beautiful but
telling myself affirmative it doesn't
work on me what about for you what works
well for you
um so I don't know with regards to the
trauma thing but certainly in terms of
what makes me feel better I have to
change my mind with the body so if I
don't train if I don't get sunlight if I
don't move if I get cold and hot within
a day I feel phenomenal I went to uh
sauna and Copeland's place that I love
here in Austin called kuya and I took a
bunch of friends from the UK day
yesterday and we did maybe two rounds of
heat and cold and you get out of the
cold tub after wanting your life to end
for quite a while and one of the guys
said dude I challenge anybody that's
having a bad day to do that and not feel
amazing after you've finished so for me
changing the mind with the body is a
good place to start trying to think your
way out of overthinking is like trying
to sniff your way out of a cocaine
addiction it's just not it's not good
it's not gonna work yeah you're not
going to find the solution there and
there's lots of research to suggest that
as well people think they get an anxious
thought they start thinking their way
out of it and now they're trapped with
their thoughts and traumas the reality
is most research shows that it's
actually in your body the anxiety exists
in your body so by changing your bodily
State rather than your mental state will
actually help so like you said though
the plunges and so you take like cold
baths and stuff like that would that
work and it works yeah yeah it's
incredible it's the most it's the most
reliable way to increase dopamine and
then to keep it at a relatively good
level before it tapers off so most most
of the time there's sort of this
dopaminergic seesaw so you will get some
but on the other side you're going to
pay for it kind of like going out and
drinking and then you have a hangover
that's kind of how the dopaminergic
system works but cold exposure is one of
the few things that allows you to get
that increase and then it will slowly
taper back down to Baseline without you
having to pay this overdraft in a way so
it's very reliable way to to improve
dopamine so going back to the trauma
thing yeah what are some of the common
trauma patterns that show up in people's
behavior or there's a mindset that many
people may hold is there a common
relationship between something that
somebody believes and a common trauma
that has gone through in that past
yeah and and I think one of the things
people always believe they're far more
unique than they are especially in
relationships they always say to me they
get to a session they're like oh you're
never going to hear anybody like this I
have to tell you this and I asked two
questions and I can answer I can tell
them they predict their exact behavior
and what trauma basically is it's not
necessarily that you're abused or you're
attacked or anything like that
essentially you had needs that were not
met as a child in some way shape or form
and children we're not designed to
detach from our parents because we can't
survive by being detached from our
parents so we won't ever stop loving our
parents who don't meet our needs but we
do start loving stop loving ourselves we
stop investing in ourselves because we
we're thinking that we're not worthy of
investment and it's all unconscious so
what happens in relationships is they go
into the relationships with the
preparation that this person is going to
hurt me so I have two choices I either
cling on to them for dear life and hold
on to them and I can almost live in
their skin and monitor their behavior
and try and control everything they do
and become preoccupied with them and
watch when they're last online and just
think think about them all day every day
just so they don't leave me but in that
desperate attempt to kind of keep them
we end up suffocating them and fighting
with them to keep them and the
relationship ends or you can go down the
other route which is to become
completely independent completely
avoidant dismiss emotionally detached
emotionally guarded and almost have a
partner there but act as if they don't
exist have a separate room don't get
invest too much maybe have alternative
Partners here and there and have the
avoidant room which I'm sure you've come
across before so we either go extreme
anxiety or extreme dismissal and
avoidance and that is really the two
trauma responses when it comes to
relationships when you're looking at
trying to fix somebody's attachment what
are the places that you start at
um the first thing I always ask them to
remember is your anxiety or your defense
mechanism is not symbolic of love what
happens is people seem to think if
they're preoccupied with someone and
they're thinking about them all day
every day and they're trying to control
their behavior and they're watching them
I must be in love I can't stop thinking
about this person I know he's toxic I
know he's you're not good for me but I
can't stop thinking I'm watching when
he's online they mistake that
preoccupation as love they think I must
be in love with that person when really
it's a signal it's a signal to show that
your trauma alarm has been activated
this person is not soothing you or you
are finding the problems in this
relationship but either way it's not a
symbol a symbol of love it's a symbol
that something's wrong it's a signal
that you haven't been able to soothe
yourself or this relationship is not
soothing so we have to dissect which one
it is is it the person or is it your own
anxieties so we start with their
response or it could be a man that says
she's really great I love her she she's
done nothing wrong she's perfect but I
don't really care about her I don't
really like her I don't know I need
space you feel I feel suffocated but
when she leaves I really miss her and I
always get her back but when she's with
me I always end up texting other girls
that's still a trauma response there's a
part of you that's craving distance but
intimacy at the same time so we look at
it and we try and relabel the behavior
because the avoidant will think I don't
care and the anxious would think I'm
obsessed and I care too much both of
them are defense mechanisms that Dynamic
of the guy with the girl when he gets
the girl it's too suffocating and when
he's away from the girl he's wistful and
wishes that he could get it back is a
dynamic that I have seen so so many
times why is that so common what is it
that's going on inside of the male brain
that's causing that
well it would be a lot of men think it's
just the chase they like the Chase and
once they've got conquered they no
longer like the girl there's an element
of that and that does happen but
majority of the time it's when the man
had emotionally distant parents when the
parents didn't take the time to truly
get to know them and be truly there for
them in terms of their emotional needs
what happens is they assume nobody's
going to be there for their emotional
needs and the best way the ego defends
itself is saying I don't need anybody to
be there for my emotional needs I don't
need to talk about my feelings I don't
need to connect I don't need someone in
my space all the time so they replace
what they didn't get with what they
don't want and so when they meet
somebody who's trying to emotionally
connect with them they label it as I
don't need this go away leave me alone
and they'll distance themselves distance
distance but when she leaves they're in
pieces so they obviously do need it they
just don't know how to navigate this
need with alongside their trauma so they
end up pushing away the very people that
they love and and trying to love them
and they attract clingy Partners what
happens is the avoidant person always
attracts the clingy because if a distant
independent person another distant
independent woman they don't have the
glue to keep them together so they also
don't feel validated by somebody who
doesn't care to see them but when they
meet that clingy partner they get the
validation I'm loud but then they don't
have to put in the work because they
know they'll she'll love you and cling
on to you regardless so the clingy and
the distant are always together one of
the other common archetypes I think that
I'm seeing at the moment are people who
continue to create validation even once
they're in a relationship this is
facilitated by social media obviously
the fact that you can get
um let's say that you have an argument
with your partner and then you decide to
post a thirst trap photo or you decide
to start following a bunch of different
girls is it cheating uh well we don't
really have any rules around
relationships to say you know if you
haven't had sex with somebody that's
definitely cheating but this is more
kind of passive aggressive
Global I'm just gonna do it I've got an
excuse if they do bring it up it's
because of their insecurity they almost
deserve it because we just had this
argument and it's kind of there's a lot
more degrees of freedom between in a
relationship and out of a relationship
and everyone can [__] about in the
middle section there what is it or why
do certain people crave this chaos
within relationships and this sort of
validation outside of them
because they've lost touch with
themselves and what I mean by this is if
I've had a fight with my partner and my
instinct is to go message another man
am I doing it because I want like this
other man and I want to speak to this
other man or am I just trying to even
out the playing field of this fight am I
just trying to even out the score now
when you're so in touch with yourself
and you love yourself and you go what
happens when you love and trust yourself
is you go by what you truly desire
you're not trying to win a game what you
truly desire you don't post a picture
online to get the to get comments
because you're not in the mood you're
just on a fight with your partner but
when you're playing a game it's game on
every time you've annoyed me game on so
when I speak to people and clients
especially they'll say oh you know he's
just been liking another girl he hasn't
called me in a couple of days I'm gonna
go see my ex I'm like just stop do you
want to see your ex or are you doing
this because you're upset he hasn't
called you because if you want to see
your ex go ahead and do it but if you're
doing it because he hasn't called you
you are not connected to yourself you
don't respect or love yourself you don't
know yourself you are going by what he's
making you feel but take back the
control go by what you want to do and if
you want to see that because you would
do that even if this partner didn't
annoy you then listen to yourself but if
you if it's purely to even out the score
I promise you're going to leave with
shame and guilt and shame and guilt are
the two worst emotions a human being can
feel because you direct that anger at
yourself and it's a a it chips away out
of self-respect so I that's why I think
people turn to Alternatives they've lost
touch with their authenticity are you
from a Muslim background
I'm Pakistani Pakistani so we grow up
Muslim yeah yep and grew up in the UK
and now live in Dubai yes okay
given that very traditional in some
regards upbringing in terms of the
values that you've been raised with
yeah what are your thoughts and what are
your insights around this current trend
of
um uploading childlessness and
demonization of motherhood that we're
seeing coming from certain corners of
women's advice at the moment
it's uh do you know what I have to say
it's so alien to me because when you are
from my culture our parents live for
their kids I I this is all we see so
what will happen I remember when I used
to go to school with you know my friends
were English and they'd say oh my mum
and dad are going on holiday or my mum
and dad are going to restaurants and I'm
like my mum and dad don't go and do
anything without us they just literally
they they just live for the kids and
their money is saved for the kids
wedding days and everything is just like
the kids the kids the kids they they
sent her around probably too much around
the children so my culture was always
like are your life starts when you have
kids what are you going to do other than
that that's what life is about and then
growing up in an English world where
it's slightly more do what makes you
happy do what makes you happy now I
think the balance is do what gives you a
purpose now nothing gives you more of a
purpose in life than when you have
children because their soul existence
psychological and physical depends on
you and I'm not saying do it because you
want to you know feel loved or anything
but it's the only thing that will exist
when you die so when you don't have
children it's very difficult to see how
all this loving memories and
intelligence and experiences you've had
and not be able to pass that on to
somebody wouldn't you if you've had a
fulfilling life want to then pass that
Legacy and keep yourself alive
throughout the generations and I think
what's happened is we're so pleasure
seeking that we the only thing that is
guaranteed is death and the only thing
me and you both know is that we're going
to have a funeral now if on that funeral
there are still remnants of you that's a
life that's a beautiful life and it's
going to continue forever you don't
truly die when you have kids but when on
your funeral there's nobody but you've
got to travel 100 countries and you've
got to sleep with every man you wanted
that day is going to come for all of us
and that's the only day we're guaranteed
we prepare for it by leaving a legacy
because that's what we're designed to do
so when we reject that there must be
some kind of trauma somewhere and you
know me I think my answer to everything
is always some kind of trauma but I do
think there's some kind of rejection to
your true needs because we're designed
to survive and reproduce so if those
things were rejecting there's some
disconnect with your true needs I think
what it shows is just how powerful
culture can be the fact that yeah right
two things right survival and
reproduction culture as of yet hasn't
been able to step in and encourage
people to throw themselves in front of
open traffic but it has been able to
step in and uh how do you say like
perturb someone's natural inclination
toward having kids I think my current
sort of viewpoint on it is that there's
a lot of alternative things that people
can do uh there is this slow life
strategy and
it the costs of having children are
immediate and obvious it's going to stop
you from traveling to Bali whenever you
want it means that you're going to not
be able to wear those cute heels that
you intended on wearing it means that
you're maybe going to get stretch marks
and maybe you're gonna have to your body
is going to gain weight and maybe blah
blah blah so all of the costs are up
front and all of the benefits are kind
of down the line and even mothers in the
moment the moment-to-moment experience
of the life isn't that pleasurable but
it's very meaningful and in a yes IIT
and a culture that optimizes pleasure
above everything else
individualistic atomized
compartmentalized hedonic maximization
every single second trying to say here
is a reason that you should sacrifice
all of the things right now that you
love in society says that you should
enjoy for something which is in the
moment going to be very difficult and
may pay off some dividends down the line
and none of your mates are doing at the
moment so there's no mimetic sense of oh
well you know I've got this culture of
young women that are having kids for
every person that doesn't decide to have
kids that's another person that isn't
influencing the people around them to
have kids and you get this sort of
runaway effect like the are not
numbering from covid so I I see that I
really do see that at the moment there's
been a lot of talk and that's why I flew
to next to your country of residence or
debate about this sort of crisis of
masculinity that we're facing at the
moment do you think there's a crisis of
femininity at the moment do you think
that women are struggling for good Role
Models right now
I do think so and you know I I know from
my personal experience I don't have a
role model online I don't have a role
model and if I do have any kind of role
models it will just be like a some of
the men in the field that have done
really great work in Psychology but I
can't tell you there's a single woman
that I've ever watched growing up and
thought I want to be like her and that
that's not because there's anything
wrong with the women out there maybe
it's my values don't connect with
current environment but what I would
love to see is how we can Embrace every
part of being a woman I just loved I
love being different to a man I have no
desire for complete equality with a man
it just doesn't make me feel good
knowing that I can do everything a man
can do because I'd rather what's the
point of you if we do everything the
same I'd rather you complete the areas
of my life where I'm deficient and I
complete areas of your life where you're
deficient and when I was you know living
in England and working around a English
environment and stuff there was such a
desire what I found with feminists and
particularly in the English environment
there's no
specimen of human being that is more
privileged than the English white woman
in my experience there's no human on
this planet that is more privileged than
the English white woman and when I used
to see how much they would complain
about the oppression they experienced
and I just thought to myself you
definitely still have more rights than
somebody like my father who's got a bit
of an accent and he's definitely Muslim
and stuff like that you definitely have
more of a privilege than him and you
definitely have more of a privilege than
you know this the Caribbean guys or the
Nigerian guys or the Muslim guys when
you go to the airport you definitely
have a privilege but because people are
so almost dying to be a victim they
would complain about such small things I
remember like being in schools and the
teachers would complain like oh God the
music is too many male answers that's
inequality and I just thought you don't
know what suffering is you haven't
experienced it but you want to because
it gives you meaning and purpose and so
I felt and this is probably going to
sound bad but I felt like it was the
most privileged members of society
complaining about being oppressed when
they haven't seen true oppression and
and I always say to feminists that you
know from that background like do you
want the Privileges of men or do you
want the Privileges of white men because
I promise you if you're in a white woman
you don't want to have the same
treatment as a black man when you're
pulled over by the police or by the
airport staff as a Muslim man with a
beard are you sure you want to be
treated like a man or you just want to
be treated like a certain type of man
because I promise you you're very
privileged and I felt it even as a woman
with what like I have pretty much white
skin I feel incredibly privileged so I
felt like it's not a gendered thing it's
a class thing you have more privileges
through your class and your skin tone
and your appearance then you do have
gender so I just didn't understand the
battle and that's what led to my
disassociation
one of the other problems I think is
that
a lot of the women that espouse this
sort of victimhood narrative and say
things like we need to smash the
patriarchy and chivalry is dead because
we don't need men they are luxury
beliefs that are held by women who
are sufficiently financially stable and
live in a society that is fine for them
now yeah I'm totally open to believing
that a high-powered female psychologist
or lawyer or attorney or whatever uh
maybe doesn't need to have the man pay
for the first date or hold the door open
for her or make sure that she gets home
safe or whatever because that's she is
absolutely fine
consider for a second the woman that is
on benefits living in some run-down
Council estate in the north west of the
UK who maybe the partner that she's with
didn't even complete secondary school
maybe he has no gcses he had an absent
father home no one ever taught him how
to be a man perhaps those codes of
chivalry weren't constraining to him
they were assisting like things it is
one as far as I can see it is one
Continuum from you should make sure that
your date gets home safe to you
shouldn't hit your wife like it is a
single Continuum all the way down that
there is an asymmetry in the safety that
men and women have and as soon as you
start to open that door this isn't me
saying that like if women want to walk
home safe they're like in 20 years time
they're going to be hit but my point is
that as soon as you accept the fact that
there are certain things that men can
offer that women can't as soon as you
take those away Men start to ask the
question well why should I bother doing
this and this and this and this and this
and it's start The Dominoes begin to
Tumble so a lot of these opinions are
held by women for whom they are never
going to be affected by the bad
externalities of doing it it's the
luxury belief of all of the people that
live in gated communities With Private
Security saying defund the police eat
[__] yeah like eat [__] it's got [__]
all to do with you this has got nothing
to do with your life this is you being
able to proselytize about how much you
uphold the the underclass and the
working class that are being
persecuted by police that come through
their neighborhood you don't live there
you don't deal with it and it's exactly
that here's what it is here's what it's
like you know when you're watching a
great football match and you're so
engrossed in it you almost want to wish
you supported a team I don't watch
football but when I watch the World Cup
final I was wishing I was which
whichever team I was like whoever scored
I was on their team I wanted to be part
of that Glory because at least you feel
alive now when you're not involved in
any kind of Oppression any kind of cause
any kind of anything you start to lose
purpose when you're watching a boring
football match you start noticing how
cold it is how [__] the food is but when
you're watching something so exciting
you forget all of that and you feel
alive what I see when I see these
incredibly incredibly privileged women
fighting for women's rights it's like
they've watched
um they've watched the trauma of other
people and they so want to feel alive
because human nature is designed for
survival when you've got it so easy you
still crave meaning and purpose you
still crave kind of some kind of
hostility so they jump in the fight that
they actually they don't need and B
they're already so privileged and when I
see these kind of feminists who are
arguing about men's rights and putting
men down when while they live this most
amazing life what it screams to me is
you're dreaming to have a meaning and
purpose you want to be on that football
match you want to be in that boxing ring
and because you don't have it you're
going to identify with the people that
do and almost have a pseudo oppression
and that's what it looks like to me you
are so great I'm so grateful to be a
woman especially growing up in the west
speaking English do you think I would be
here speaking to you my English accent
wasn't like this what a privilege I have
so to see those people who have this
complain that they're oppressed it's
laughable because I'm from a different
world when I go back to Kashmir it's
laughable to me because women gender
rights don't matter when you haven't got
food on the table
given the fact that there is a challenge
perhaps even the women who are
performatively doing this victimhood by
proxy thing
they would probably like to have better
role models and better values to focus
on in your opinion what what are the
things that can predict a healthy
psychology for a woman what where are
the places that affirm that she could
stand uh that would make her life better
and would also make the lives of the
people around her better
I think the key I I know I talk a lot
about how everybody's similar but in the
sense that everybody's also different
it's authenticity here's a trick for
mental health as a woman you remain
completely and utterly authentic and you
can't know that if you jump on other
people's bandwagons if you imitate the
culture around you if you imitate the
other people's experiences if you adopt
values that you haven't actually
experienced so a lot of feminists will
say oh oppressed men men in the
workplace and then I'll say to them who
oppressed you at the workplace oh my
boss she was a [__] I'm like she was a
bit yeah the guy was great the manager
was great he was lovely but the woman so
I'm asking them what is your lived
experience is it really that men haven't
been oppressing you no they've never
actually treated me that badly right the
moment you lose touch with your
authenticity you start living in a
delusion and when we live in a delusion
we are almost we're just it's a
predictable slow and slow steady suicide
emotionally and psychologically so start
to live according to your authentic what
do you truly want well do you truly want
to sleep with this guy to look cool and
act like a bad [__] no you don't how do
you feel afterwards I feel [__] so why
are you doing it do you really want to
text your ex after a fight with your
boyfriend no but I just want to get even
why are you doing it do you truly want
to post that picture of you out there
and just have to deal with DM's order
and you truly feel good when you post on
not only fans no but I just want a bag
what do you want to do with that bag I
don't know I don't even use them
stay in touch with your authentic self I
promise you're secure to any
psychological or mental health issue
do the equivalent but for men
I'm sorry do the equivalent that you've
just run through there but for men the
authenticity side I would say it's
similar to the I would same thing for
men I think if you want strong
psychological Health slightly different
I would say for men the key for a man is
self-control for women it's authenticity
you have to say authentic as possible
because our body tells us so much our
body will tell you when you're craving a
child when you're getting angry when
you're getting hostile because our
hormones are all over the place for a
man your body sometimes speaks against
you it will Crave You Know pleasure all
the time your key to successful mental
health is complete and utter
self-control in terms of your mind body
and soul you control what you consume
you don't watch everything you don't go
into every desire you control who you
put yourself into you don't go and sleep
with every single one everyone anyway
you actually gain far more self-esteem
when you reject women than when you go
when you accept women there is that man
that has a women that he's rejecting
feels far greater than that man who
can't say no to anybody because he's
jumping at the opportunities
self-control even with what you eat when
I have clients that come to me and
they've got a bit of depression I don't
I I say to them until you go to the gym
and until you lose weight there's no
conversation that me and you can have
that will change your self-esteem it
won't do it because me and you can have
a great conversation but when you go and
take a shower when you go and get
undressed in front of a woman everything
I've said to you won't mean anything so
self-control is what you eat go work out
don't have to have a six fact but
self-control now when a man practices
self-control he becomes such an
unshakable being because none of his
friends can make him drink alcohol if he
doesn't want it no woman can make him
spend money on her if she he doesn't
want to no gambling machine can make him
waste money if he doesn't want to he
becomes
indispensable as a man so self-control I
really believe is the root of a man's
self-esteem I think one of the
interesting circles that's difficult to
square in some of the corners of men's
advice at the moment is that
self-control and self-mastery are a big
deal that you should train hard you
should be disciplined you should get up
on time do your cold plunge and your
sauna and your gym workout and work on
your business and read and
be able to quote Marcus Aurelius but as
soon as you have a plethora of women
that are in front of you you should
sleep with as many as you want so
self-controlling yourself masteries stop
at the boundaries of the penis which is
a an odd sentence the most dangerous
place to stop because children key word
the most dangerous place to stop your
self-control is doing is your penis
because your penis is responsible for
life now if you don't Master
self-control when it comes to who you're
having sex with you are now you know
we're living in a times where
pregnancies everything favors women you
get the wrong woman pregnant for the
rest of your life you are tied to this
woman and you can go to jail for not
paying child support for a woman who
might even be lying who might not even
you might not even be the father of a
child that's what a risk having sex with
low quality or low quality people means
you risk the rest of your life it's a
death sentence if you get the wrong
person pregnant and even if you don't I
always say it lowers your standards you
can't can't be doing that so this is
what I don't understand a lot about the
masculine kind of frame especially
online dating for the younger generation
they teach men to just have no
discipline when it comes to sexual
behaviors what do you think about that
I think it is you're a man so I'm asking
you because I maybe it's something I'll
never understand I'm not sure I think
that there is so much status assigned to
being attractive and being chosen by
women
and you know everything else that you do
is a proxy for that in any case maybe
some of it is to do with survival but
the nice car and the fancy watch and the
red bottom Louboutins and the follow
account on Instagram and the Blue Tick
and all of that stuff they are all
proxies for look at my make value go up
right and the most direct way that you
can prove to yourself that you'll make
value is high and you can prove to
everybody around you that you make value
is high is to sleep with women and you
know I've worked in The Nightlife
industry for 15 years so I saw this
firsthand I was in the trenches of of
all of this stuff that was going on this
is the the currency that everybody is is
using uh so I understand I understand
why it's there I mean you know none of
this none of these conversations were
happening 15 years ago nobody was saying
guys maybe you should try and keep it in
your pants maybe the height of masculine
Essence isn't going and sleeping with as
many women as possible because
these conversations simply weren't
around uh I'm sure if you'd read enough
books you would have probably been able
to reverse engineer them but they
weren't happening as accessibly as they
do now so I think that that's the reason
that it happens but I would agree I
think that if you are uh taking your
sense of self-worth from your body count
as a guy
it's a very fragile place to take it
from there like there just has to be
something deeper than that yeah well
what I always say is men that sleep
around with a lot of women or chase
women especially if she's like a quarter
of their age and stuff like that it's no
different to a man with new money when a
man grew up with money you don't see him
posting his Lamborghini his watches and
stuff like that it's just what his his
dad had a Rolls-Royce he used to get
dropped in a limousine to school he'd
never posts about this stuff because
it's he gets on a private jet to go to
places that guy doesn't post about money
because it was never a deprivation now
when you're sleeping with so many women
and you especially when it's like just a
shortcut for status what that signals is
there was a deprivation in self-esteem
at some point in your life there was
some rejection from women and you're
compensating by having no frugality when
it comes to selecting a woman now so for
me when I see a man sleeping with lots
of women I don't actually see it as a
status symbol maybe because my brain is
psychologically like programmed I see as
compensationary Saturday for low
self-esteem as child just like the man
that's posting his brand new watch in
his brand new car perhaps he didn't grow
up with wealth so it's the same thing
when you show that you're sleeping with
a lot of women to me it signals you
couldn't have like got a lot of women
when you were growing up and perhaps
it's now time to make up for lost time
it's a selection mechanism as well right
because there is a large cohort of guys
that can't get laid and what you're
doing is you're advertising to the world
I'm not one of them I don't you don't
need to worry about me I'm not part of
that particular group of pathologically
broken alone terminally it's in solitude
men
um one of the other things that's
happened is a
how would you say
uh reverence for the Middle East and for
the values that have been coming out of
that
what are or what is unique about the
dating scene in Dubai let's say that
there's someone listening who's never
been or that they know about Dubai is
what they've seen on a couple of tick
tock videos what's yeah interesting or
different about the dating scene I would
say Dubai is not very representative of
the Middle East and it's got a
completely different culture to like
Muslim values and culture in general the
reason being is it is a playground for
The Rich And Beautiful the entire city
is Beverly Hills so what happens is the
richest man in the world flock to Dubai
it's got amazing perks if you want to
make a lot of money it's just it's where
it is
um and any City where there's Richmond
there are beautiful women it's just
always the case wherever there's
Richmond there's beautiful women so the
playground is completely different it
really separates the men from the boys
both for men and women so what happens
is a woman has to really feel like
everybody's a competition so if she
hasn't worked on anything besides her
looks She's gonna find it's very it's
um it's a difficult place to meet people
because if you think you're the
prettiest girl in the room there'll be
another pretty girl there'll be another
pretty girl there so it's hard for her
to stand up and for the rich guy if he
leads with money he will learn that's
not enough for the women out here
because she knows a hundred millionaires
so what happens is both these people who
brought their kind of their their
trophies to come to Dubai the beautiful
girl and the rich man realize that here
it's a dime a dozen so you have to bring
something else to the table but the
problem is the culture and the
environment is so distracting it's
difficult for Partnerships to connect
and last around time even though
everybody's craving it most people here
are expats they haven't got their mom
and dad and cousins and family so
they're craving a sense of home but
because it feels like it's so far like
far-fetched like the ego defenses come
in and they just think well I might as
well just play in the mud while I'm here
so it's slightly different to the rest
of the Middle East I would say do more
options mean more happiness yes
it's the exact opposite more options
means less happiness they've done so
many studies where they looked at
people's reactions to food in a food
court compared to a home-cooked meal or
even paintings and had lots of choices
or just given one there's always higher
satisfaction when there's no
Alternatives because your brain then
doesn't imagine Alternatives but our
brain has this ability where it can
literally experience what we imagine if
I say to you imagine ketchup on ice
cream you can almost taste that you can
almost taste that if you think about it
enough you can taste it when you have
Alternatives Imagining the alternative
is enough for you to start a desire
there and when you don't have
Alternatives you kind of stay focused
but when you do have Alternatives it
means the satisfaction is reversed so in
a place like Dubai that is swimming with
lots of people with lots of money and
lots of women filled with lots of
silicon there are a lot of distractions
uh endless distractions and even if it's
not the women it's the environment
restaurants are fantastic the bars and
clubs and stuff to do the beaches are
amazing the water will dance for you sit
and have dinner and the water fountains
will go up there is just such a a so
much pleasure everywhere I mean it
really suits me well because I'm quite
extrovert and I I would never say in a
bad way for me it works well but for
anybody who craves more of a calm
peaceful environment I don't know how
conducive a city like this would be
I think that you're right I am
I wonder about
what the Muslim Community thinks of the
recent trend of white Western guys
saying that they're going to convert
that they're now going to follow has
this been a conversation that you've had
with your dad or anybody from your yeah
do you know what it is becoming common I
do think Andrew has a part to play in
that I think Andrew has had a part to
play in it and I think in general it's
um I think what's happened is the left
has become so loud that people are
seeking conservatism again and I think
that because Dubai has become popular
and the idea of the whole gender debate
and women becoming so promiscuous now
people are thinking I need I need a
solution I need a fix okay if you're
looking for not promiscuous women Dubai
is not necessarily the place to go and
if you're looking for a real
representation of Islam Dubai is also
not the place to go the last place to go
I would say if you're looking for a
non-promiscuous woman there is nowhere
um there's nowhere worse than Dubai
because the promiscuity in Dubai amongst
the men and women but like I always say
it's the only city in the world where
the women are far more promiscuous than
the men far more because what's happened
to the women in I don't want to say too
much but what's happened to the women
that come to rich cities is they come
emotionally detached they come with the
idea that I want to meet a rich man now
that woman is completely different to
the woman that comes to a city and says
I want to fall in love and have kids now
that emotionally detached woman who
comes I want a good life is never
emotionally invested and here's the
mistake a lot of rich men make they seem
to think that if they can support a girl
and give her a good life loyalty is a
given but what they're forgetting is a
woman that craves a good life doesn't
seek emotional intimacy she seeks
financial intimacy now any woman who
doesn't seek emotional intimacy is far
more likely to stray so they're the most
likely to be cheated on is these men
that spoil their women
because loyal women want to be spoiled
by time they don't want to be spoiled by
possessions and a lot of these
successful men don't have time so they
naturally filter out loyal women and get
the ones that are okay with the
financial investment that's again
another difficult sort of hypocrisy or
tough Circle to Square from Men's advice
around the you know looking for
emotional intimacy is simping for women
but paying them in gifts and flying them
all over the world is somehow being high
value the problem the problem with that
is that you are making an incredibly
fragile Foundation upon which to build
that relationship now the cope from that
going one order down is well it doesn't
matter I'm not bothered about building a
relationship because use them and like
you discard them we'll just get on to
the next one and you go okay well
in that case we're not really talking
about the same thing one person is
having a discussion about how to sleep
with lots of women and use their Air
Miles as much as they can and another
person is looking for a relationship and
I think that one of the concerns is much
of the advice that gets put out on the
Internet is given by men that are
optimizing for short-term relationships
but taken by men who actually want to be
optimizing for long-term relationships
yeah you know if you're super clear
super high in sex drive super high in
sociosexuality super low in
agreeableness super low in commitment
very commitment diverse very avoidant
attachment
you are going to construct a world in
which your philosophy meets those
desires for yourself yeah but if that's
the most popular Creed that's put out on
the internet and all of these guys who
don't have that same Baseline of
personality do begin to think well maybe
maybe this is what I should be doing
maybe this is what should fulfill me you
yeah you end up using a philosophy that
was designed for a different machine
than the one that you are
yeah exactly that and here's the thing
with a kind of here's what being a
simpius right here's let me just
summarize what it is it's not about
loving and investing in your partner
which is often the case they seem to
think that anybody who loves or invests
or wants a long lasting or who is loyal
is a simp here's what being a simp is a
woman crosses your boundaries and you
still accept and not only accept you try
and get her back that's what simping is
you everybody's got different boundaries
but if you've seen a woman cross your
boundaries many times you've seen
unacceptable behavior and instead of
them withdrawing your love you then
shower her with more love to get her
back that I can understand is a simp but
somebody who vets a woman correctly and
then puts explains their boundaries and
here's what a boundary is it's very
simple the moment you feel something is
not great you communicate it you don't
test your partner to see if they break
it again and so you just say look I
don't like it when you don't call me
after a night out I just want to make
sure you got home okay it's uh oh I
don't like it I think that outfit it's a
little bit too revealing on a night out
can you just be a little bit more
mindful you say your boundaries now if
you don't say your boundaries and you
allow a woman to completely disrespect
him even though you're feeling it you
know in your soul she's disrespecting
your boundaries but you're still begging
her to be with you and she's doing
unacceptable behavior and you're still
begging her then you fall into the
category of a Sim but that can happen
with women men anyone can do that but
strong boundaries create good neighbors
the moment we put our boundaries up
people then know how to behave around us
and we become simp free we become immune
to being a Sim but if you have no
boundaries but you're learning the
tricks of how to get women oh I pay for
a woman here that but you've got no
boundaries and she's cheating on you and
you're still paying for her then you're
not learning what actually is creating
the
um circumstances for a healthy
connection
what are you looking forward to working
on over the next couple of months what's
the impact that you want to have
um I think what I would love to focus a
little bit more on is the impact of uh
pornography on men I think pornography
has had a huge impact on men and women
and I would love to kind of focus if I
could have one mission in this whole
kind of social media space it would be
to draw light to the impact of
pornography on men's mental health
because what pornography does is it
teaches men women are wild and are
promiscuous so in the real world they
look for wild and promiscuous women
without realizing that wild and
promiscuous woman then breaks their
boundaries and hurts them and they end
up in a slow suicide in the form of
depression and they don't realize that
it's all connected whereas if they stop
sexualizing women so much through their
use of pornography they would have
higher standards of what they accept and
want in a woman and then they could
maintain a relationship better and then
that depression would slowly disappear
but I think pornography is kind of where
I would love to focus on
and also just kind of undoing some of
the damage from the Red fuel
conversation
how do you mean here's another I feel
like it's done the exact terrible impact
that feminism had at Women's belief
about men red pill kind of did the exact
same for men it gave them a home for the
men that hate women gave them a home but
it's in the wrong hands it's okay when
it's in the hands of psychologists and
people who understand human nature but
when it's in the hands of a 27 year old
boy who just wants to make it in a
social media or somebody whose life
experience is just making tick tocks and
he's the one teaching men how to
um how to view women it's dangerous it's
super super dangerous so I would love to
undo the damage of some of that
where should people go if they want to
check out more of the stuff that they do
uh of what they do or what you do oh
what have I do sorry I saw the
psychology on Instagram YouTube and tick
tocks audio psychology I tend to put
everything up on using the same handle
so if you do want to find more and yeah
I also do one-to-ones if you do want any
kind of um one-to-one coaching I am
available so I do I really appreciate
you thank you thank you so much for your
time thank you what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face